la créativité
ce don exception
là qui nous donne le pouvoir de
de ressentir et d'exprimer
idée d idée aussi folle que celle
d'envoyer des hommes sur la lune ou plus
simplement décrire un discours le
pouvoir d'exprimer ses idées
c'est exactement ce qui m'a fallu pour
écrire cette conférence quand j'étais
face à ce problème
c'est quelque chose que vous avez sans
doute connu l'angoissé de la page
blanche
c'est incroyable comme phénomène des
idées j'en avais plein mais impossible
de les former les formuler j'ai pris un
peu de recul et j'ai changé de méthode
je me suis lancé un défi j'ai fermé les
yeux
je me suis dit que je démarrerai cette
conférence avec le premier objet qui ne
tomberait dans les mains j'ai tâté mon
bureau et cet objet en question c'était
celui-là un trombone alors la première
chose qui me vient à l'esprit c'est web
était mal barré
mais en y réfléchissant bien c'est
parfait comme objet c'est quoi un
trombone concrètement
ce n'est qu'un fil de fer qu'on a replié
trois fois sur lui même
c'est génial comme idée partir de rien
et d'inventer un objet comme sa pratique
ludique et économique est ce qu on
pourrait en dire autant de nous
sommes-nous créatif on va faire un petit
jeu je vais vous donner 30 secondes pour
imaginer 5 utilisation que vous pourriez
faire avec un trombone
c'est clair pour tout le monde c'est
parti pour imaginer ça il va falloir
sortir un peu de votre zone de confort
penser quelque chose d'un peu plus
informelle quelque chose de moins
habituel c'est un exercice qui est assez
compliquée qu'on n'en a pas l'habitude
de le faire
vous allez voir qu'on tourne vite en
rond c'est un très bon exercice jeu max
et cherche à les plus que 5 secondes
alors qui d'entre vous a trouvé cinq
utilisation lever la main c'est très
très peu un choix que j'avais quelques
mains levées vous êtes 180 vous êtes 190
dans cette salle c'est peu pourtant d
utilisation il y en a plein je me suis
portée au jeu voici quelques
utilisations que j'ai trouvé vous voyez
qu'on peut faire plein de choses
vous venez de passer un test de
créativité qu'on appelle le test de
jackson en moyenne les adultes sont
capables de trouver une quinzaine
d'utilisation à un objet simple ils ont
plus que 30 secondes rassurez vous et ce
test vous considère comme des génies si
vous êtes capable de trouver des
centaines d'idées alors dit comme ça ça
peut paraître compliqué mais pourtant il
ya des personnes à qui ça ne pose pas de
problème c'est les enfants
et oui des enfants c'est magique
ça n'a pas de filtre ça n'a pas peur
d'avoir tort ça vous trouve toujours des
solutions
ma fille de 4 ans on a fait une belle
démonstration mois dernier elle s'était
mis en quête de nettoyer le brouillard
je fais la voie et j'ai dit mais comment
est-ce que tu comptes y prendre je vais
aspirer les nuages avec mon aspirateur a
été nuage tu vas les métros dans un sac
poubelle
mais ces petits un sac poubelle pour
tous les nuages elle m'a regardé en
fronçant les sourcils
elle est l ouvrir le tiroir elle m'a dit
mais papa tu vois des sacs poubelles
j'en ai plein alors sur le coup je n'ai
pas su quoi répondre
j'avais juste cette image de ma fille
comme ça
la chasseuse de brouillard quoi qu'il en
soit j'ai trouvé ça génial sort comme
une soeur ken robinson a fait une
expérience très intéressante au sujet de
la créativité des enfants
il a fait passer ce test à 1500 enfants
à plusieurs étapes de leur développement
en classe de maternelle il était 98% à
trouver des centaines d'idées
certains imaginaient ce qui pourrait
faire si l'objet était grand s'ils
étaient fabriqués dans une autre matière
vous aviez pensé à ces choses à moi pas
mais cinq ans plus tard en repassant ce
test ces mêmes enfants n'étaient plus
que 30% avoir autant de succès ajoutez
encore cinq ans ils n'étaient plus que
12%
comme le disait picasso aujourd'hui
cette chute créative c'est un problème
notre société est en contraction
économique aux ressources limitées
un monde qui se transforme face aux
enjeux climatiques numérique
industrielle tirer partie de vos packs
de votre capacité créative est une
compétence d'avenir clé on peut se
donner se poser la question mais qu'est
ce qui participe à cette ut créative
est ce que c'est la maturité
l'expérience les responsabilités c'est
beaucoup plus simple que ça nous ne
faisons rien pour entretenir ce don
imagine c'est ce qu'on appelle la fixité
fonctionnel c'est comme si on vous avait
mis des oeillères un jour quelqu'un vous
a dit tu vois cet objet c'est un
trombone et tu peux accrocher des
feuilles avec vous avez intégré l'idée
et vous êtes passé à autre chose prenne
plus naturel c'est comme ça qu'on
apprend vite
mais ce mode de penser à une grosse
contrepartie celui de conditionner et de
cloisonner votre esprit à ne chercher
qu'une solution par problème à ne voir
qu'une utilisation
un objet de manière inconsciente
nous sommes acteurs de cette chute
créative c'est comme quand vous
pratiquez langue étrangère
moi vous la parler et moi vous pourrez
vous en servir il ya quelques années je
m'étais donné un objectif retrouver cet
esprit innovant en développant ma
créativité mon agilité cette faculté à
vous adapter quelles que soient les
circonstances la résilience pouvoir
tirer profit des obstacles des échecs
que je rencontre et enfin développer mon
enthousiasme avoir une attitude positive
et bienveillante au quotidien c'est des
qualités humaines
mais ce sont également des vraies
compétences d'avenir et quand on
n'apprend pas trahi comme ça il faut
changer d'état d'esprit
cet état d'esprit j'ai trouvé en
m'intéressant au design un monde qui
m'était complètement inconnu pour moi le
design
c'était ça quelque chose de beau
d'élégants de classe des purs et moi mon
monde à l'époque c'était ça
ça fait quand même un sacré choc des
cultures et ben en fait j'ai énormément
appris le design ce n'est pas qu'une
affaire d'esthétique
le design c'est avant tout un travail de
réflexion de conception et
d'amélioration c'est une vision qui
gravitent autour d'un état d'esprit
qu'on appelle le design thinking
c'est une approche on vous apprend à
penser les travailler d'une autre
manière
c'est une approche où votre
préoccupation première
ce n'est pas l'outil à l'objet de ce que
vous faites c'est l'humain qui est
derrière
l'humain qui va l'utiliser le design a
une approche profondément humaniste pour
illustrer ce propos j'aimerais vous
raconter une petite histoire qui m'a
beaucoup marqué en tant que papa au 19e
siècle en angleterre il lui est une
représentation pour enfants au victoria
hall à la fin du spectacle
on annonça la distribution de jouets
gratuits à l'extérieur
essayez d'imaginer un peu l'hystérie que
ça a provoqué auprès des enfants dans
l'assistance âgés entre 3 et 14 ans
c'est une marée humaine qui s'est ruée
sur les portes de sortie pour aller
récupérer leurs jouets le problème c'est
qu'à cette époque les portes s'ouvraient
vers l'intérieur les enfants se sont
écrasés les uns derrière les autres ce
qui a eu pour conséquence 183 enfants
décédés et c'est grâce à un travail de
design que aujourd'hui toutes les portes
dans les espaces publics s'ouvre vers
l'extérieur et que la plupart du temps
elles sont équipées de grandes barres
latérales qu'il faut pousser
voilà ce qu'est le travail du design
pensé au facteur humain
nous pourrions tous pensé au design
thinking au quotidien pour nous
améliorer
on a toujours besoin de trouver des
solutions améliorées un processus
d'entreprise d'avoir des nouvelles idées
on a déjà tant à faire pourquoi faire
simple quand on peut faire compliqué
vous avez certainement entendu cette
phrase mais elle est vraie on n'imagine
pas à quel point nous sommes champions
dans l'art de compliquer les choses
ça fait plus experts ça montre qu'on a
bien travaillé mais le vrai rôle d'un
expert c'est justement d'avoir cette
compréhension de ce qui est complexe et
c'est lui qui doit simplifier pour que
ce soit accessible pour les autres
personne ne le fera
si vous ne le faites pas en tant
qu'expert je garde aujourd'hui trois
enseignements du design thinking
j'aimerais partager avec vous qui vont
profondément changer qui m'ont amené à
ces quatre qualités que je cherchais le
premier c'est savoir développer son sens
de l'empathie
le problème quand on est expert set
tombait dans son propre piège de croire
que sa bonne expertise est plus apte à
cerner les besoins
l'empathie va vous servir à ouvrir les
yeux
on va prendre un petit exemple les
toilettes publiques
imaginons que je demande à quelqu'un
dans patick de moderniser des toilettes
publiques
il va pas chercher à changer les
robinets ou installer des toilettes
écologiques
il va prendre le temps d'observer les
gens qui font des va-et-vient en
toilettes sans aucune perversion ville
mais il va être frappé par une chose
pourquoi les gens sortent des toilettes
en utilisant leurs coudes ou emballant
leurs mains dans du papier et si par
hasard
l'innovation même ce ne serait pas de
changer le système d'ouverture des
portes en partant sur ce point vous
créerez une vraie innovation et vous
règlerez un sentait d'un problème de
santé publique il faut savoir qu'en
france une personne sur trois ne se lave
pas les mains aux toilettes ce qui veut
dire que l'une des personnes à côté de
vous
[Musique]
mais se lave pas les mains ça laisse
rêveur voilà ce que peut apporter
l'empathie penser à petit ces petites
choses que vous ne remarquez plus au
quotidien le deuxième point c'est
apprendre à sortir de votre zone de
confort à être curieux à apprendre de
nouvelles choses ne pas rester cantonné
est ce que vous connaissez ou ce qui
vous rassure il y a plein de choses à
apprendre pour progresser
regardez ce petit insecte j'ai marqué
son nom parce que je n'arrive jamais un
grand souvenir
d'ailleurs les scientifiques sont très
forts pour inventer des noms complexe
alors on pourrait s'arrêter là et dire
boîtier en voici un petit scarabée quoi
sauf que ce petit insecte a une faculté
assez étonnante c'est qu'ils arrivent à
trouver de l'eau dans le désert dans une
époque où on cherche de l'eau c'est
intéressant
chaque chaque matin il va au sommet des
dunes et il attend le lever du soleil
l'air va se condenser sur cb sa carapace
et grâce à un système de canaux les
gouttelettes vont ruisseler vers sa
bouche ce système a inspiré d'un
ingénieur pour créer des filets à
brouillard qui a permis dans des zones
reculées où l'eau n'est pas disponible
ban en avoir
ça c'est une innovation pourtant ils
n'ont rien créé ils ont juste observer
et répéter ce qu'ils ont vu le dernier
point c'est la persévérance savoir être
agile face aux aléas savoir rebondir
ne pas avoir peur de faire des erreurs
qui a dit que des erreurs étaient mal il
est naturel de faire des erreurs nous
sommes humains l'erreur nous permet même
de progresser
l'erreur vous permet même de trouver des
opportunités
ne cherchez pas à réussir du premier
coup ou aller au plus vite ou au moins
cher sous prétexte que le temps c'est de
l'argent manqué son objectif par manque
de prévoyance ou d'anticipation
c'est aussi l'argent
si l'on en croit cette étude américaine
85 % des emplois dès 2030 n'existe pas
encore
vous n'y serez donc pas formés adopter
une attitude agile et créative c'est
faire un investissement long terme sur
vous même c'est d'adopter des qualités
humaines qui vous serviront toute votre
vie
quel que soit votre métier quel que soit
votre milieu
vous avez tous été des enfants
il ya donc du génie qui sommeille en
chacun d'entre vous sachez en tirer
profit
c'est ce qui marquera votre différence
ralph waldo emerson a une belle phrase
au sujet de sa il disait que le but dans
la vie ce n'était pas l'espoir de
devenir parfait mais la volonté d'être
toujours meilleur
ce qui m'amène à vous poser cette
dernière question et si vous aussi vous
deveniez les designers de votre vie
merci
[Applaudissements]